dashing through the snow in a one horse
open sleigh all the
fields oh Gordon be careful that red
light it's flashing but it goes off
again it's fine relax and how lucky are
we to be here in the middle of the
saffron Harvest ho ho ho jingle saffron
can only be picked for 3 weeks every
year today we're heading to the Valley
in the foothills of the Atlas Mountains
for the Harvest of the world's most
expensive
spice talking about expensive spices yes
what has been your most
expensive Christmas present that you
received my one if I tell you you won't
believe me go on my wife went to an
auction for charity yes for 3,700 LB One
pubic air from madona
what that's disgusting it comes in a
transparent box in a nice frame it's
about this long and what color was it
it's a little be like your color blonde
what it's come back on again now it's
come back off again the light what have
you done I don't know I said red lights
come on now it say stop don't go in the
ditch you're you're on the ditch sh
games it stop now it's try
and turn it on try
this lock
it see we are here and we need to get
there right it's a flipping long
way we're supposed to be picking sath I
want to look at you too why are you
going so fast oh why cuz I hate hanging
around well let's go for a light job no
no
let's go come on know my shoes are not
good for doing that what are you
doing I'm doing the Italian
Jing oh Gordon yes look the man with the
donkey
hello Gino now see there look can we
then
left oh he said yes okay thank you thank
you yeah I'm going to go there
okay watch out there's a goat and three
chickens here just hear those Sligh
bells jingle ring
ting come
Ona
slide come to Jerusalem to celebrate
Christmas with me
really we are together right we are
together that's the most important thing
he's about being together for
[Music]
Christmas look at
the you know in a sort of funny way I'm
happy that the van broke down really why
because we never going to experience
something like this it's like we've been
back 2,000 years
agoing
with you know the name of zafron come
from the Arabic zafan and it means
yellow some people say it's as effective
as a stimulant for people who take who
have ATD what yeah people who are
hyperactive like Gordon that's why I put
saffon in my coffin that's why do you
yes that any
eggs
chicken
[Music]